on va faire un petit rappel des faits
parce que hier dans tpm plus on avait
parlé de the island et lors du débat
mathieu de jean baud avait notamment
parlé de l'âme
et apparemment ça a réveillé les bim
j'ai touché juste je m'énerve autre a
alors arrêté l aile par bit la même part
vite car vous allez nous dire ce que
vous en pensez je regardais je vous
avais dire fait de la peine c'est qu'en
réalité la plupart de ces célébrités
pour pas dire 80 100 % de ces célébrités
ne ferai jamais jamais cette émission
est dans ces conditions si la callas
marché sylvain peu d'argent madame ça
cartonne plus tôt mais sa carte et 6500
euros par mois 10 kw à la mairie faire
plaisir dans les interviews elle même si
tu veux dire un truc là dessus qu'ils y
croient alors mathieu donc l'âme vous a
répondu ça a été très chaud
matthieu delormeau donc je te plaît
ferme ta gueule à lacaune dit je te
plait je fais s'te plaît mais terme
d'accueil ta gueule fils d'avocat au
barreau de paris et ton salaire avec la
société de production plus tp mp c'est
sûr que tu dois pas manger des raviolis
en boîte
honte à toi de rabaisser les gens devant
la france entière tête de gland donc là
apparemment elle a des photos de vous
matthieu delormeau t'as fait quoi
d'intéressant pour gagner ton pognon à
part montrer ton cuche était pmp ou ce
qu'on sait déjà beaucoup alors il en
rire plus d'un c'était une règle qui
dépasse et j'ai rien de grave donc avant
de critiquer ma carrière regarde ton
trou je laissais hier c'est pas un
bouffon qui va me rabaisser à 46 balai
devant la france entière crime est allé
quand même je ne pourrais pas à ce que
je découvre quand même et à l'âme quand
même je voudrais dire une chose que
matthieu delormeau me critiquent donne
son avis d'eau blême
mais me rabaisser elle et elle a été
fixée alors qu'est ce que vous voudrez
bien je pourrais pas répondre avec la
même vulgarité nucléaire aurait pas
m'adapter
donc voila mais c'est sûr que quand je
lis ces tweets ce m'étonne qu'à moitié
que sa carrière est pris l'eau bref je
reste
je n'ai pas humilier j'ai dit qu'est ce
que je dis tu peux aussi sur l'algérie
vérité si sur la forme j'ai été
maladroit je m'en excuse auprès de
l'amci sûr en revanche sur le fond mais
je maintiens tout ce que j'ai dit aucun
people ne me fera croire que la ferme
célébrités zirides on est tous à ces 10
pouces et pour le dépassement de soi
c'est peut-être 5% des people le reste
disons la vérité c'est pour l'argent est
retrouvé en général un petit peu de
gloire parce que tous ceux qui le font
non plus de carrière souvent et plus
d'argent c'est pas une honte tout ce que
j'ai dit c'est que ça me fait de la
peine de les voir dedans je pense que la
place des people n'est pas dans la ferme
célébrités n'est pas dans inland ça me
fait de la peine quand je les vois et au
moins qu'on soit honnête disons la
vérité elle y est allé pour avoir un
petit peu de notoriété et un peu
d'argent elle même de l'interview a dit
qu'elle gagnait plus du tout d'argent
qu'elle vivait de rien donc je n'ai rien
sorti comme un faux on attend qu'on
vienne me dire que ces gens là font ces
émissions où ils sont humiliés piqué
dégueulasse pas maquillée tout pour le
dépassement de soi
alem c maximum 5 % le reste c'est des
menteurs même âge comprend d'abord la
réaction de l'âme quand on voit ça dans
ce sens devant son poste
effectivement je pense qu'elle a été
humiliée elle a été blessé donc je pense
que c'est dur et effectivement sont
aujourd'hui sa réaction peut être
violente contre toi mais après moi je
pense qu'on est tous les sbires de
quelqu'un en fait et c'est très dur non
tu te tais les deux bêtises tu te faire
une carrière sur la longueur canton un
chanteur un acteur un écrivain s'est dit
fier de son coup dur géraldine quand on
parle comme ça sur voilà c'est ça
d'avoir fait pas une carrière c'est déjà
bihoué voilà